[Music]
these days you can learn practically
anything from the internet so the
concept of being an apprentice craftsman
may seem a little old school but here in
the countryside of Kochi Japan there is
a small blacksmith workshop where the
apprenticeship style of learning has not
completely disappeared these blades are
called NASA and they are used by
professional wood cutters here in Kochi
which is a heavily forested region of
the country they are the tool chiefly
made by this master craftsmen Maha Bua
nothing hazardous we had no good idea
every day due to yet detangler good
you'll impress me the man demanded even
head tag and Mohammad Abdu moved ahead
Tokyo they owned a Hondo Laguna's
Missoni but three years ago after nearly
a lifetime of working alone matsumura
was joined by a young man and now my
watch it's you this visible to our
mikaze I know me not I was famous when
[Music]
he learned about matsumura kikuchi left
his manufacturing job in the city and
approached the aging master who was
hesitant to take on the young man as an
apprentice a yellow star imaginable more
from that origin idea how could everyone
I gave the name the correct amount due
to me everything
my home decor yet where you plan today
and for Kikuchi it's not only about
learning from his master but learning
how to think like his master imam
internet to dog a high C no so his
miracle tomatillo Niki mosquito well sir
duck is a bikini I know a buddy is an
O'Conner I got a boo-boo more silica
toga Dickie not a day
listen or no mikata across its mystery
what oh gosh I see no meter to stay mo
sono hometown okay I gotta go back out
tonight o omnes una mano toka mo no tea
no Vicki no I told when was another en
toda genome OneNote this gives us a
gothic architects you go to toast ever
tie him music Ashish go to one with her
she was up there party content a
secondary music a sequel to The Hunger
yuri gagarin women of there
we re talking about Joe's insta hoga
Etowah
[Music]
when it comes to Japanese metalwork
knives usually get all the glory but in
the city of Sakai where blacksmithing
goes back to the making of samurai
swords in the 14th century one craftsman
has built a legacy on something a little
different
scissors to split paper food and of
course bonsai trees
this is the a su héroe hirokawa who
works under the brand Suzuka
we Akiane Hassan Madoka for jokes who do
I know kasi honest
[Music]
hirokawa is a fifth-generation scissor
maker and he has been doing it for half
a century he is the only traditional
scissor craftsman left in all of Japan
Okayama state killing machine I told
domina you know gamma which was rushed
yeah something about you enjoy and I
also feel Samuel but I still know who I
will put up an army time is equal to the
time
mm I will cut that schedule it's good
they are about yo cooking it takes
hirokawa a week or longer working 10
hours a day to make a pair of scissors
three to four times as long as making a
knife and that effort is reflected in
the price well honey the one day down in
Devon most it's oh no no no they do
anybody say sorry what's that I know how
humble you know about cotton also get a
lot
but what are you gonna do with scissors
that expensive to answer that
here's Masakazu Yoshi couch a craftsman
of bonsai for a master like yoshikawa a
key in crafting perfect bonsai is the
perfect pair of scissors gusano they
know it's good to my roundest gizmo
semi-auto Geneva yaku Sasuke Santo des
neige by Ishikawa arataura after know
what Arsenal in ekq soukara a body
honto she eaten a chicken cacciatore
story
[Music]
the ridiculous between your
psychoanalyst the body he has an obscure
NATO novel autonomous the body hee-ha-ha
media river
I know so Kubasaki Tatum oh so good need
amaze you I'll tell anybody could see a
spot talkative under a new chicawa still
remembers his first pair of Suzuki
scissors nobody will know more on
iñárritu no more neighbourhood you see
how can you dare question your motives
or delegate I would I just gotta know
Camarillo dismay sono hitomi amor datura
evils al Qaeda unanimously but for
hirokawa he's only just gotten started
they questioned about the medina in my
email was hypocritical Dohan Gustav
Conchita modern media Kodomo cognitive
clean IDs
[Music]
yep and I saw dark hanataro face - now
that was happening in shanxi Institute's
Irma La Ventana emotional boolean Roman
siddhartha channel amou haedongcheong
Santa de Leon Katara under hatches your
action you're failing thoroughly under
hockey Chancellor ping hood Dahlia or
knife therapy started 2500 years ago in
ancient China as an alternative method
to traditional medicine romances are
Taiwan's you're enforcing the MU 1 ha 90
Hangzhou that I was young tolerance if
800 order tell how sooner hash out
certain day neither son told him talk
yeah yeah no gasp Angelina Jo has been
practicing in teaching knife therapy for
14 years
Roku is only Benelli alpha he banned
another thought you told heart itself
always shadows with hope and how I saw
some sensitive [ __ ]
non singular solitary setting on your CD
with chains and Mahato I knew it without
sitcom the whole tone i sat down since
alex is your hometown
what you're not sure but becoming one of
the 18,000 qualified blade masters takes
real work where I'm had should go with
the whole fall should see me know me yes
oh my doll else's sannyasins solution
needs Altos onion sitting at a fancy but
not show me Josh young the knives are
specially blunted and are made based on
a varied ratio of steel and iron it is a
customary practice to hover the knives
over burning sandalwood and store them
next to meteorites to maintain the
knives lightness and efficiency me :
yeah so cool to see that all truth so
humid Oh bad I'm Tom Paine young female
fan Tyson being okay so being on the
moon while the idea of knives may seem
unconventional this tradition has seen a
recent surge in popularity across
Taiwanese cities so Taiwan and more the
function Ouma tolerance
changsik important de alva sensation
efficiency nakita mo father no es Omaha
a young dog Marinaccio bunions lighter
Talia Kushinagar harder issue through
the language on shelter no fashion
Saruman coriander seeds oh yeah nice and
easy at Siemens OH - I chose an aura
pansy a volcanologist it Chiquita's
kaleipus cousin Emma is generally travel
palma fair-skinned play don t cameo
who's Audrey Sugano llama to discuss
ganado mise en su s to limit 11s as a
voter Obama a tremulous apocryphal a
fetus see total context map Ella quiere
mudar a pariah near default makyo say
principal mala restoration limited
bhooshan secret early personnel s
castrillo fetch me deposit more
conservative on Cesar is rich fellow to
alpha T dr. Caracciolo material is Rioja
[Music]
avocados on camera say por el cocinero
Pedro fix a programmable edit rosani
Valley boca de estilo community press
reveal the adjuster from Hawaii image a
still image in pretty tempting of it
Hong Kong to tip the docket Oh Oh
general yang Zen in consent docket
Odisha ha the firm odometer different
cities dish out Machine slowly problem
cannot adapt our unique model akuto AP
on speed totally sweet polly sujod I put
adapt easily keeper
[Music]
oh wait renew refresh when you fo frame
is confer you configure material before
treasure
Lukie foreign on Bonita Odo's Americana
dune a shot professionally particular
material equal to a in a majority yet
the person komatsuna pure-pep - who do
name do them videos of J is a support on
my soil